[Music]
I went out to dinner last night not to
brag I don't want to brag I don't want
to start by bragging but I have been to
restaurants I got cash no big deal
pfchangs Outback Boston Market check
check check but I I went out to eat and
I realized something kind of fun right
around the time they gave me my free
basket of bread that I didn't even ask
for while I was waiting for them to
deliver hand deliver an entree of my
choosing something dawned on me we live
better than
pharaohs pharaohs us better we're
everyday pharaohs it's crazy just a
regular old Sunday night was way better
than any day in the lives of the kings
of old old o o lde e that's how old
wicked old we have menus think about
that menus pages and pages of options
pharaohs one option just be like ah I'll
have whatever the hunter
killed oh what's that the hunter was
killed oh then I'll have the
hunter can you make that well done he
was
gross if you showed a pharaoh the menu
from Cheesecake Factory his dick would
fall
off and bars could forget about
substitutions I want that Q card framed
in my office and feros could forget
about substitutions oh here he
goes we're all at Ruby Tuesdays making
huge changes to the menu at no
additional cost just like oh yeah could
I have the uh veggie burger but could
you make it a turkey burger but cook it
on the grill that you cook the veggie
burgers on cuz I want a turkey one that
kind of tastes like a veggie one you can
yeah just cuz I asked just now yeah and
you'll keep refilling my Coke until the
end of time
than what about delivery food from other
cultures brought right to your doorstep
that's amazing and they're penalized for
taking longer than 30 minutes that's
like a big inconvenience for most of
History if you wanted Italian food you
had to go to
Italy that's true on a boat you want
some Italian get up boat and gather up a
group of able-bodied seamen are you
listening you think it's hard getting
six people to agree to a restaurant on a
Friday night try getting six people to
agree on where to set
sail that's a bigger
debate instead of a drawer in your
kitchen full of takeout menus you just
have a drawer filled with
maps maps and a compass and keepsakes of
people who died trying to taste
mozzarella
sticks he didn't make
it yeah
organic there'd be one guy walking
around the neighborhood rubber banding
maps to Thailand on everyone's
doorknob one house with a sign no
Maps so the next time you feel down on
living in a world that isn't exactly
perfect just remember it could be worse
you could have been the most powerful
person in ancient Egypt
[Music]